taylor branch your book about martin
luther king jr and the civil rights
movement is titled parting the waters
it's over a thousand pages
long and you've been quoted as saying i
wish i'd been able to do it in fewer
pages but there were dimensions i just
had no idea about
when i started what dimensions were
those
oh many many many i used plural
i didn't realize the the groundedness of
this
black church that the civil rights
movement came out of the black church
to such a degree that it did and that
the black church was such a separate
world
every bit as it was a whole society in
itself
i came to think of it almost like
renaissance the world of renaissance
princes
because uh the black
church in the church in the black
community substitutes for a whole lot of
roles that in the white community are
played by other institutions
banks newspapers courts mayors
and the black preachers are often uh
all those things rolled into one even
today but certainly at the time
uh the king and the kings as the king
family which was kind of like a
it's like the rothschilds or the medicis
or something like that they
had a national presence so that was one
dimension that
that overwhelmed me to try to bring that
to life because i felt you couldn't
understand king unless you understood
that you couldn't understand the civil
rights movement without
without it also the um
the fact that so much of it took place
behind the scenes
whether you're talking about with the
kennedy white house the fbi
uh and within the movement that there
was so much
fractious tumultuous debate behind the
scenes so
i knew that's what i wanted to get after
because what frustrated me about civil
rights history is that we only see it
whenever it would break into the
white world at a sit-in or in a march on
washington or something and that's
you know five days out of out of ten
thousand
but the rest of it was a swirling and
very complex world
how did you know that was there if what
we had seen was only those few days when
it came to the surface
because this is why i wrote the book or
at least one of the reasons i wrote it
personal curiosity i i grew up in the
south
dr king city much younger a
teenager i was in college when he was
killed i was a teenager
for most of the movement i was a first
grader during the montgomery bus boycott
i was paying no attention to this i was
paying no attention to politics at all
frankly my family regarded politics as a
game for people who couldn't get honest
work
and so i i paid i was completely
apolitical i have no memory of the 1960
election
but when birmingham happened and i saw
it on the television
the photographs of the hoses and the
dogs and the
sound bites of king's speeches it really
woke me up it changed my life in a way
that has never
receded saying how can this be because i
grew up with a kind of norman rockwell
view of america we had licked the
japanese and the germans
and polio and everything was right and
so i felt the power of this movement and
heard it in king's voice
and i wanted to try to recreate since it
changed my life got me interested in
politics and eventually into writing i
wanted to know what the components were
of something i just felt a breath of it
blow by me it wasn't aimed at me and i
certainly wasn't looking for it but it
changed my life and so
it seemed to me that it had to have a
tremendous dramatic life
force power and when i'd read about it
on all i would get was morality plays or
arguments about who was more militant or
not militant enough so
i knew there had to be more to it and
what i discovered was that it was behind
the scenes and it was very complicated
and
i had to learn some church stuff and
theology and a lot of
clandestine politics to penetrate it
getting back to one of those unknown
dimensions you talked about you've been
quoted as saying you can't understand
king unless you know what it was like to
be a black preacher growing up in his
world the black aristocracy
what was that world like well it was um
it was this world of preachers that we
were talking about it was a
world in which king new manners
he knew for example that when he
switched girlfriends one of the first
things he would do
would be to introduce this is when he
was a teenager even he would introduce
his girlfriend the girlfriend of his new
girlfriend to the pastor of his old
girlfriend
and even sometimes before he told his
old girlfriend he was breaking up he
wanted the pastor to know
and he didn't have to say anything he
just had to bring her over and introduce
her reverend so and so this is so
this is so-and-so and that told the
pastor that if his member
the old girlfriend came in for
consultations he would know what to do
he would know that things have changed
this kind of world even in social
relations and in national political
relations uh
marriages the the entrances he knew how
to enter exactly at
the right time he would always be late
he he practiced preaching he knew how to
take up the collection he knew the trade
craft of the pulpit the politics of the
pulpit if you told him
that so-and-so was going to appear in
the mount moriah baptist church in
cleveland he would know
who the pastor was what the social
status was what kind of congregation it
was and by the fact that that person was
going to go there a lot about that
person's social standing so the
church is a whole world and and king the
aristocracy part of it was that the
kings were several generations
into this world as as a powerful family
such that uh martin king by the time he
was
17 or 18 years old on the strength of a
phone call from his father couldn't be
invited into
a pulpit in new york that had a church
that had ten thousand members and where
he could speak to three thousand members
on a given sunday
and preachers around the world would
give their teeth for that kind of access
because it exposed them and gave them
to the great congregations and expose
them to the great preachers who
controlled the great congregations and
uh so he had that and when he would come
back to school he'd have two or three
hundred dollars in his pocket
and uh be dealing with his seminarian
class
uh in fact i was talking to one just
this week he was preaching in two
churches
six dollars a week in one and twenty
five dollars a week in the other just to
stay in seminary and here would come
mike as he called him because
mike king called himself mike that was
his birth name the name was born and
mike would come back from some giant
church and have three hundred dollars in
cash in his pocket
and he'd be something and he'd be able
to call those people on the phone and
this is before
the world ever heard of martin luther
king and this is before king
ever had anything to do with the
montgomery bus boycott so
in his own world uh the own it was an
invisible world whites paid no attention
to it and and
had not king rose risen into history he
would be as invisible now as a lot of
these other preachers
who played a major role in this story
but that nobody knows about them but
within his own world
his life had more in common with prince
charles's than it
did with mine growing up in a lot of
ways in the sense of this
awareness of a whole world of politics
and manners and the special role of the
black preacher
you've mentioned his father several
times in the king family dynasty
how was how was young martin luther
king's life shaped by his relationship
with his father
well i think it was shaped very much by
his relationship with his father his
father was a character of tremendous
will
he grafted himself on to a church
dynasty
through his father-in-law who was
himself a great preacher a national
officer in the black baptist church
reverend a.d williams
i think that there's probably it's
probably fair to say that there was some
gold hunting in daddy king's courtship
of this elegant woman
uh the big preacher's daughter daddy
king by his own confession
could scarcely read or write was
semi-literate and set out to court
the daughter of one of the wealthiest
preachers in town who was a college
woman and was
lived in this super refinement at
spelman where
the all the students had to wear gloves
up to their elbow and
they could only receive callers on
saturday for half an
hour if the card was presented in almost
a clark gable like fashion
very super refined here's daddy king who
spoke in eyes and uses and could hardly
speak correctly preaching out in the
country church and wanted to court this
woman he had to force himself to get
schooling because he learned that and he
submitted himself to the humiliation of
starting school
in his 20s literally stuffing himself
into tiny
desks next to kids putting through
a proud and ambitious man put himself
through that and
telescoped in education maybe not the
greatest education because he never
developed polish speech
but he did that and came back and
pronounced himself ready to get married
and they said
i got high school and they said well our
daughter can't marry
a man with no formal education a country
preacher and
so then he walked into morehouse college
and forced his way in there and they
told him he was not college material and
he blustered his way in got a couple of
years of education
finally married her
that was and then the old man died and
there were many people who said dr king
married his way into the pulpit because
he leaped over maybe 40 or 50 years
worth of social advancement in the
highly stratified black church
through that marriage and by the the
death of his father-in-law but he
inherited the church in the depression
that went
bankrupt it was practically padlocked
and then you saw a further extension of
daddy king's ferocious will and that he
took that church
by a series of business adventures and
inventions and other
acts of business-like character he was a
business preacher he was a preacher for
the business age built that church into
4 000 members the largest baptist church
in black baptist church in atlanta
against the tides of the depression in
only two or three years a remarkable
character but a fundamentalist a man who
was mainly interested in business the
corporate church
whose ambition by his own confession was
to own a big brick house and to be on
the board of directors of a bank
so he was a he was a republican preacher
an old style preacher and
and one of the things that bothered his
son so much a uh
showboating preacher he did whatever
ralph abernathy talked to me about
walk the benches daddy king it's a term
of art
in the black church that in the ecstatic
portion of a fundamentalist sermon
a a truly gifted preacher would come out
and walk along the backs of the pews
preaching an ecstasy and people would
swoon in the aisles
it's called walking the benches because
it was uh uh
something that if for in the emotional
fervor of a black church would would be
seen as the essence of the
the greatest thing a pastor could do but
to young king who is already
more intellectual than that it was
primitive it was like vaudeville
and the theology embarrassed him and yet
so
all through his life he went through
with a
very strong bond with his father being
proud of his strength and proud of the
fact that he could
hold and nurture a church but
embarrassed by his theology and often
ferociously at odds with him about the
meaning of
politics about the meaning of the civil
rights movement and religion
who else impacted on young martin's life
what writers and philosophers do you
think had the most impact
well i think an awful lot certainly all
the characters in the bible
impacted on him a great deal and i i
mean certainly the life of jesus
but which is well known and to be
expected but also
the the jewish prophets when he got into
school
he by his own confession and these
papers were fascinating for me to read
he went through a prolonged period of
skepticism
religious skepticism when as he put it
the shackles of fundamentalism fell from
my mind at a very early age
and then as he got into college
developed into somewhat of a free
thinker
and um in seminary had to
reconstruct his reconstruct his
religious
faith and he did it several different
times once as a social gospel preacher
he believed he could preach ethics he
could preach
uplift kind of john dewey positivism
education
doing the right thing that there would
be love in the world and we could
abolish evil if only people were
educated
and then a theologian named ron holt
nieber
reinhold niebuhr destroyed that whole
thing by arguing basically that there's
no evidence in the world that people
become more christian or less cruel or
less inhumane
as they become better educated the fact
that some of the most inhumane things in
history
have been done by the most cultured uh
the highest cultures and the most
educated people that through king for
another loop and so
but never helped him shape another
a new faith basically that i think
by the time he finished his phd or even
before in seminary i think that he had
formed the core
of a philosophy in both religion and
politics
that never really changed what changed
his was his experi
his experience of movement what it what
was required of him to give witness to
that philosophy
and what he had to risk as far as this
heritage of himself
as the professor the elevated
cultured black aristocrat that he was
born
good evening and welcome to our program
we're spending 90 minutes this evening
talking about dr martin luther king jr
and his role in the civil rights
movement our guest is taylor branch
he's written a new book called civil
rights america in the king years 1954 to
1963 the title of the book is parting
the waters
we'll be going to the phones in about 10
minutes we'd like to hear your thoughts
on these issues
you'll see the phone numbers
periodically across the bottom of your
screen
in the eastern or central time zone it's
202-628-2525
in the mountain or pacific time zone
202-783-2727
again our guest taylor branch the author
of parting the waters
most of the reviewers of your book say
that your revelations about the role of
the kennedys
in the civil rights movements is one of
the the new keys to your book
what was the relationship between martin
luther king and the kennedys
i think that it was one of struggle
basically
the reviewers speak of revelations to me
it's a it's a
long wrestling match particularly
between
king and the civil rights movement and
robert kennedy
basically the kennedys were on the
defensive the movement
was always pushing them to demonstrate
that freedom was a reality here in the
united states and throwing up the race
issue throwing up the segregation laws
throwing up the
the black poverty rate the fact that
they couldn't vote i mean
one thing after another and it was very
difficult for president kennedy for two
reasons number one his primary
identification was with
international politics and the free
world he
was fond of quoting emperors and british
prime ministers and british kings and
he he saw himself he relished his war
his role
as the leader of the free world more
than eisenhower i think in fact that's
one of this
that's the spirit of kennedy at least i
think a large part of the spirit is that
eisenhower belonged to the generation
that had won the war but not sought the
war and saw the superpower status as
kind of a burden
whereas to kennedy it was the
opportunity of a millennium
to to be able to sit astride the globe
to represent all that wealth
all that power and all that idealism all
at once in a global context
was like you know alexander the great
and
but and then with given that focus
and him speaking of freedom around the
world which is what he projected himself
defending it was a profound
threat to have always martin luther king
and these students and
in these prosaic things that here are
people who are not even free enough to
sit down to have a
bite to eat or a bus is stopped in
birmingham because
mobs won't let it move another inch
during the freedom rides
because it's got an interracial
ridership on that
as i put it sometimes the president can
make president kennedy feel as though
when he's going into the international
councils of the world
in europe or to meet khrushchev as
though he's got mud on his shoes because
the civil rights movement was
just kind of made a mockery and of a lot
of things so he was
he was defensive about it that was the
one reason that he was defensive the
other of course he was a narrowly
elected president who depended he got
his greatest margin of victory in the
south
that was solidly democratic and
wholeheartedly segregationists and which
was rising up against
the implementation of the brown decision
in school integration the massive
resistance era
so president kennedy had severe
civil rights problem in the political
problem in
maintaining his mandate to govern on the
one hand
and making his principles of freedom
consistent and makes sense in light of
the challenge that's being forced on
them always by the civil rights movement
basically um i think both candidates
were on the defensive
i think if they had been able to snap
their fingers and make segregation go
away they would have done it
but that was not a realistic hope and so
what really happened was
if they had been able to snap their
fingers and make martin luther king go
away they would have done that too
they had a better chance of making that
happen by playing their cards and trying
to keep the movement submerged
and keep king quiet keep everything
orderly but it didn't work
did the kennedys try to manipulate the
movement to their to their game
to what degree certainly many times at
the very beginning
of the administration they they tried
successfully
for a time to manipulate not only
dr king but the students of snick
to who of the student nonviolent
coordinating committee who had been
having the freedom rides
and who the previous year had started
the sit-ins to get out of what they call
direct action
to get out of demonstrating seeking out
segregation and
volunteering to go to jail to go to jail
and stay in jail
basically the kennedys sought out to
make a deal with those people
to convince them that they're really
important strides in civil rights we're
not hamburgers and launch counters but
were voting rights
and a lot of people were convinced of
the soundness of that approach
because from voting flow all other
rights and as long as blacks
were disenfranchised in the south there
was not very much hope
that they could rise to full citizenship
no matter where they sat on the bus or
what kind of
lunch counters they could eat at so
basically the kennedys
made a deal with tax consequences a
clandestine deal largely that if they
would
withdraw from the confrontational direct
action and channel their energies into
voter registration where there were
federal laws to protect them
the kennedys would do everything they
could to make sure to get foundation
money to support them financially
and to protect them in the case that
they were
harassed or intimidated or lynched or
beaten
there was a furious a lot of misgivings
within the movement a terrible
argument about whether this was the
proper course or not
and basically snake did that
and dr king supported it although dr
king said we can do both
the snake people did that and later felt
very much betrayed
because they felt and as even the cynics
said at the time that this was merely a
ploy by the kennedy administration
to get them out of demonstrations which
were which were public which were
causing them to be criticized which were
embarrassing them
getting them to do voter registration
which was quiet and which would
get out of the headlines and also those
votes that would be registered would
tend to be black democrats voting for
the kennedys uh for making it a little
easier for them to govern rather than
more difficult
then of course what happened was that
when the great resistance
even to the voting strategy grew up and
those people who were
registering voters under the assurances
of protection from the administration
began to get beaten
began to get even murdered the kennedys
found it almost impossible
to protect them and in effect
it put them in a terrible position
because having asked these people to go
in there and assure them that they would
be all right when it came time to live
up to the promises of assuring
protection
it was almost impossible to do and it
was politically
costly because the only way to do it
would be to send in troops or marshals
or the most visible uh
signs of federal authority and the
things most hated and resented in the
south so
all there were a lot of deals and a lot
of manipulations of this sort all
through the kennedy years
in relationship to civil rights in those
times how were the kennedys being
manipulated by j edgar hoover
kennedy's were being manipulated by j
edgar hoover uh in a number of ways
so was king i i portray it as kind of a
triangle
with each of them trying to trying to
maneuver the other two
uh dr king was trying to get more fbi
involvement in the south because
compa and protection of workers and
enforcement of civil rights statutes the
fbi was far better than the local police
nevertheless later on he also knew that
the fbi was harassing
and resisting and counseling the
kennedys not to
make alliance with the civil rights
movement on
grounds of alleged subversion from the
standpoint of the kennedys and hoover
excuse me the the kennedys hoover
and robert kennedy were in a ferocious
battle even before
civil rights emerged as a major issue in
the administration
i think it's important to realize it was
not all over
politics or racism or personal hatred
for
for blacks or discomfort on the part of
hoover who was an old-fashioned man but
that was not the whole case
hoover's fbi had grown from 300 to 5 000
agents during world war ii on the
strength of its
spy function to protect america against
the nazis
after world war ii it stayed at 5 000
rather than shrinking back to its
original level
even though hoover didn't get what he
wanted which was to be the cia
and in consolation he got the loyalty
programs which basically opened up a
permanent peacetime political role
for an enormous percentage of the fbi
manpower
that's that was useful and he made use
of that all through the mccarthy period
but by the time robert kennedy
became director uh became attorney
general
he felt that this was an appendix of the
mccarthy era
and that he was outraged by the fact
that in new york city for example there
were 400
agents who were checking librarians
on various other people for signs of
subversion
and red squads and stuff like that years
after the communist party had
had collapsed and there were only four
fbi agents working on organized crime
and i think robert kennedy would have
preferred something like a reversal of
those priorities
but hoover was wedded to the political
role it gave him enormous power a
leverage
and basically this war came
to rest over dr king because hoover came
became convinced partly out of personal
animus and partly because he was trying
to protect that political role
that if there was subversion and he was
going to protect his role in ferreting
it out
it had to be within the civil rights
movement because it was causing
upheavals in the whole country so if
there was no subversion there where was
it
so it was a battle to protect what he
was doing and the way he conceived of
the fbi it was a battle against
dr king whom he did not like in
particular and the civil rights
movement they did not like in general
because it would have forced a
revolution in the fbi
hoover had five fbi agents who were
black
all of them were basically his personal
servants including the two men who were
who drove him in la halla california and
down in miami florida to the racetrack
on his vacations were made fbi agents
basically just so that they would be
subservient to him
and his personal doorman and his home
chauffeur and i mean
all it would have it was inconceivable
to him that he could have been
comfortable in an integrated fbi
so it was a combination of all these
factors we'll be taking your calls in
just
several minutes for taylor branch author
of parting the waters america in the
king years 1954 to 1963.
you see the phone numbers across the
bottom of your screen how long did you
think it would take you to write this
book and how long did it eventually take
uh 1981 began pursuing a contract
uh to do the whole thing through 1968
through king's death
and the disintegration of a civil rights
movement
in three years 1954 to 68.
it's now been seven years and it's in
two volumes the first volume is out
going through 63. so it's taken seven
years to do
half of it really and it'll take another
at least two or three years to do
64-68 which is what i'm working on now
the johnson year
selma vietnam the poor people's campaign
the assassination
so it took a lot longer than i thought
how many people did you interview
you know i haven't counted it they're
all cited in the back well
not all of them because some people i
interviewed and did not cite but
hundreds hundreds uh probably three
hundred something like that three or
four hundred
and what form do those interviews take
mostly on the phone mostly in person
mostly in person particularly when i was
doing the preachers
i felt that the phone was not really
a suitable instrument to try to get them
to give me more than the standard civil
rights interview which was
yes and we prevailed here and then we
went prayerfully forward and met
bull connor and it was terrible and the
hoses were there you know
your standard civil rights interview was
kind of a surface phenomenon that's what
frustrated me about all this history so
it sometimes took a lot of time
being a white author doing this story
was that
a help or a deterrent in talking to
these
people from history i think i think it
was
both to some degree i think that a lot
of the black participants in the civil
rights movement that i when i first
interviewed didn't believe that i would
be serious
about it but once i established that i
was really
trying that i had worked and was willing
to work
i think some of them all appreciated the
fact that i was trying to do something
in the spirit of the movement which was
valued cross-cultural
daring basically across cultural uh
contact
education basically that cross-cultural
literacy is a requirement of life in the
in the modern world obviously it helped
to some degree having been in journalism
here and around washington
mainly dealing with white officials to
to
speak with people in the justice
department and that sort of thing
but i really don't think that it was
very much of a factor
after a while a lot of the people who
were the hardest interviews to get
were white and a lot of a lot of people
who were the hardest who were black i
don't think it had anything to do with
the fact that i was white like harry
belafoni
who was a major important character in
this but
i think it was more personal reticence
than to talk about
that uh he'd been more comfortable with
himself as kind of a showbiz political
person who did this
stuff on the side and had qualms it took
me several years and
probably about 20 letters to get him to
to agree and john doerr of the kennedy
justice department a white lawyer it
took
it was hard too to get him to agree to
tell his story but
there again it was more personal i'd
like to remind our viewers if you're
watching us
outside the borders of the united states
there's an international phone number
you can call
it's 202-737-6734 that's for our viewers
only
outside of the country if you're inside
the united states and use that
phone line we won't be taking your call
we're saving that for international
callers only
one of the advance sheets that your
publisher put out said that you had
access to wiretape
transcripts secret tapes and other
previously unavailable material
why was that material previously
unavailable and how did you finally get
access to it
well most of it is not wizardry
the king archives in atlanta only opened
in 1982 which is when i really began the
work of the
research into the book in earnest so a
lot of dr king's sermons
a lot of the uh his letters his private
papers his uh
notes his that sort of thing had not
been opened before
similarly the king center in atlanta
which is a valuable archive has the
snick papers and all of those things
that have not been
open either the kennedy library in
boston
released disclosed while i was working
on the book the fact that president
kennedy had had a taping system in the
white house
somewhat like nixon's a much more
scandalous taping system
during watergate and the first
category of materials that they released
in tapes was civil
rights i think perhaps because they
figured there wasn't very much news in
it i don't know why but to me
having worked on that subject or in the
process of it was a godsend because you
had
tapes in the oval officer in the cabinet
room of
president kennedy and robert kennedy and
at times the joint chiefs of staff
deciding whether to send troops in what
to do about martin luther king at one
point
sitting there and listening in 63 and
the president says
king is so hot it's like mark's coming
into the white house we can't have this
i can't have this man coming in here and
i've got to make it look like he's not
making me do things
these tapes are invaluable historical
resource
the book is parting the waters america
in the king years the author is taylor
branch our first call is lansing
michigan good evening
yes i'd like to ask mr branch uh if he
thinks the movie
mississippi burning is a realistic
portrayal of that incident
i have not seen mississippi burning so i
don't know but from what i've
uh what i've been told it's certainly
not realistic in the sense that it
didn't show
the civil rights movement in mississippi
which i have worked on at great length
and is one of the tremendous
i think one of the more inspiring
stories in the entire civil rights
movement is what those people did down
there so it doesn't show that at all
it has no major black characters and i'm
sure that it's fictional in the sense
that it did not show how the move
how the murders were really solved on
the other hand
for a country in which a lot of people
have no idea that
this level of violence against blacks
and whites who were involved in the
civil rights movement had occurred
it's probably a useful and very dramatic
reminder
that racial hatred did in fact reach
that level
of intensity and probably even higher
one so i think it's a mixed case but
all that is uh being said uh without
benefit of having seen the movie so i
shouldn't
probably say anything more philadelphia
pennsylvania you're on with taylor
branch
hello uh i would like to make a comment
first and then i would like to
make a second comment and ask a question
uh
there's always been a myth
produced by the conservative
element in this country that always
claimed that the left wingers
tended to be radicals and bomb
throwers and outside the law
but if you look at this historically
through that period
the reality is that the right wingers
were the ones killing the blacks
the right winger took a shot at ronald
reagan
right winger killed martin luther king
and a right winger killed john kennedy
and that most of the violence
perpetuated in this country has not come
from the left-wing radicals
it's come from the right-wing radicals
and that the violence that came as a
result of this
was a uh response to right-wing violence
and the history of it that the violence
has been
perpetuated by the right-wing in this
country and always has been
another statement i'd like to make is
that were you aware of the fact that on
the day
that lee rv oswald was killed the jack
ruby made several phone calls directly
to j
edgar hoover and i'd like to ask you i
know you can't
justify it but your own personal opinion
do you believe j
edgar hoover was involved directly with
the murder of john kennedy
and with dr martin luther king thank you
philadelphia
um the question on
there's been all too much violence
in the united states on all from all
sides and certainly during the civil
rights movement the preponderance of it
came from people who considered
themselves segregationists and
conservatives
but as to the question of the
conspiracies against kennedy
and uh and king um
[Music]
i i don't uh have any evidence
that j edgar hoover did anything more to
dr
king than to create an
undemocratic and false climate of hatred
against him particularly in saint louis
one of their
propaganda outlet papers that reprinted
fbi propaganda verbatim was in st
louis where the ray family lived now
to to that degree uh it's enough of a
burden to bear that so many
fundamentally anti-democratic things
were done
and that the j edgar hoover labeled as
subversive
a movement that has done more to deepen
our appreciation of american democracy
than any other movement in the 20th
century
and which ironically liberated the white
south
economically and and may and can and
converted
a situation that had it not been for the
civil rights movement might have
deteriorated into something more closely
appropriate
resembling beirut or south africa
so that for hoover to mistake all of
that into thinking that it was a
subversive force it's a terrible and sad
irony of american history but i have no
evidence that there was a direct kind of
murder conspiracy with him at the head
and i i don't really think that uh
it's necessary for us to uh you know
that we really need to reach out to that
conclusion because i don't think the
evidence supports it
you've mentioned in doing this book some
of the things that affected you
in looking at the movement it's a
picture from your book
tell us what this is and and how this
affected your
approach to doing this book you know
it's funny this is uh
this is the this is birmingham in the
spring of 1963.
this is what affected me when i was a
teenager
in atlanta when i saw it i had ignored
everything else
nothing else all the other years of
labor from a civil rights movement
trying
to attract notice to the injustices that
they were
directed toward had passed me by but
when they
when they sent when dr king decided to
send the children to jail
and i'm talking about not just uh 16
year olds but six-year-olds they were
seven-year-olds by the hundreds the
thousands at one point there were 2
700 people in jail in birmingham and
they had spilled over out of the jail
and into stockyards and out of
stockyards and into
tents and everywhere it was a remarkable
remarkable event and it really i came to
conclude in
my chapters on birmingham that that
everything before that in the civil
rights movement had been tentative but
once this happened the movement
spread all across the country and forced
the
introduction of the civil rights bill
and there was really no turning back
from the
movement to change segregation tracy
california good evening
hi good evening i wanted to ask the
author
a couple questions and you're
in doing your research um on dr king
did you oh i put this
um i'm really concerned that so few of
our young people
really understand what martin luther
king did for this country
and um so many of our young people just
don't seem to care
and why do you think that is and
along the same lines i'm also concerned
i know the president
reagan's getting a lot of flack for some
comments he made on 60 minutes last
night
but i'm really concerned that you look
at the jesse jacksons and al sharptons
and some of the other black leaders in
this country
and they are such a far cry from the
gentle non-violent
you know approach that dr king had and
and i was wondering if you could comment
comment on that a little bit more
because
i really am concerned that our young
people just
don't seem to to know too much
about dr king and i think that's the
fault of
we as parents california thank you for
the call
certainly it's the point of we as
parents uh how else are the young people
going to learn about dr king or about
history for that matter an awful lot of
people
young people if you ask them where
vietnam is well no
it's it's a charge to the to the older
people
frankly i'm much more upset or more
challenged or dismayed by people
my age who know very little about this
i go around to schools on king's
birthday and sometimes not on king's
birthday and
and speak to young people and oftentimes
i'm surprised by how
how ready they are to know about this
and how much how many questions they are
how eager they're not
formed against it they're curious as to
how there could have been such a
hullabaloo over buses they're curious as
to how
children could go to jail go into any
school and talk to seven-year-olds and
ask them what they think it would be
like
to go into jail where there were fears
that they would be beaten and be
fingerprinted and mugshoted and
processed right into jail and have to
stay there for 10 or 12 days
they're curious about that they'll want
to know about it and
the real challenge is to the adults to
try to to try to recapture this
history with some of the vividness that
it really had because then the lessons
will come home
tell us about this picture from your
book which one this is uh this is a
reverend king and president eisenhower
that's june 1958 the first and only time
president
president eisenhower met with civil
rights leaders
he had been pressured to do so for five
years in his administration by that time
it occurred after vice president nixon
had met with king
and uh nixon was much closer to king in
1957 than i had been prepared to believe
i didn't i didn't realize it
another one in that area was billy
graham king and billy graham had a long
period of cooperation in the 1950s
and nixon recommended that eisenhower
see king nixon
at that time it's hard to remember
blacks were voting republican
eisenhower carried the black vote in
1956 here's a president who had
had during the entire first
administration never met with civil
rights leaders
and yet he still black republicanism was
so strong that eisenhower carried
the black vote against adelaide
stephenson
still he would he wouldn't meet with
these people he was personally
uncomfortable socially uncomfortable
around blacks he was old army in that
sense
he just could not be comfortable he
would always do the wrong thing
he would be self-conscious he didn't do
it but finally
on the urging of vice president nixon he
had that one meeting and that was a
meeting at the white house dr
king was 31 years old
a very very young man but by then he was
already considered one of the senior
chieftains of civil rights meeting there
with roy wilkins and a phillip randolph
and the other
other leaders columbus ohio good evening
good evening sir
my name is wayne browning i'd like to
speak to you about south africa
situation this is in regard to your
irony of the hoover administration
i was wondering about the irony of the
uh
anti-apartheid act of 1986 actually
promoting apartheid in south africa
and are you willing for new sanctions
which will more than likely uh keep the
conservative party in south africa in
power
or are you looking for a more realistic
goal columbus
we're trying to focus this evening on
the civil rights movement in the
late 50s and early 60s here in the us do
you have a question around in that area
uh no sir i just thought this was a more
up-to-date
realistic uh happening now okay we
appreciate the call columbus we do have
other programs we have covered that
issue and i'm sure we will be in the
future so
so we'll be uh let you go on that point
and another of the reviews you were
quoted as saying that in fact
the word they used was irked that there
hadn't been a best seller
come from the civil rights movement why
not why was i irked or no
why hasn't there been a bestseller come
from for that movement well i
i don't really know um um i think that
part of it is
race is still a very very race and
religion
are two of the most sensitive topics in
all of human affairs and here we have
the two of them coming together and
movement out of the black church at a
time
we have to remember we're going back to
a time when you didn't see
blacks and white collars in the business
districts or on television or in any
position of respect you're
you're talking about legal segregation
when it was when
it was possible for people and they
frequently did argue that blacks were
literally incapable genetically
incapable
of occupying any kind of position in the
mainstream society so
for that reason we have this terrible
[Music]
sensitivity about race and i think that
one of the consequences of that is that
both
the people who are against it who are
upset about it and the people who are
trying to be progressive about it
the first thing they want to do is label
everything to show you that they're
progressive you'll call somebody a
racist
and all that means basically is that you
don't want to discover anything about
that person that you're marking them as
an enemy
or some variety of an enemy or you'll
call them they're not militant enough or
they're an uncle tom
or they're uh they're a dreamer or this
and the other
all these labels i think inhibit
discovery across the racial lines
and i think that what it means for the
history is that most of them are
are either pious or argumentative overly
analytical
they're divorced from the real ground
level reality all the personalities and
and therefore it's hard to read hard
hard to be engaged by them
my goal was to try to recreate a
storyteller's history to to make
characters that you can feel and
understand out of all the kind of
ciphers and legends of civil rights like
byron rustin
like robert kennedy like even eisenhower
like rocco siciliano who was
eisenhower's
short-lived minorities advisor in the
white house
all these people get skewered on on on
race
and they don't know what to do about it
and and they are magnificent stories and
in the movement what would happen is
that these people
faced with the sensitivity of race would
take actions and discover things would
go to jail would do things
and discover chambers of feeling within
themselves that they didn't know were
there and that's what
movement was about and so to me that's a
terribly dramatic story but it can only
be done
told in flesh and blood if you take the
trouble to recreate characters on the
ground level where they were
pittsburgh pennsylvania good evening yes
good evening man
okay i'd like to address this as a 33
year old black man
i was born a year of brown versus born
versus wade
and as far as school desegregation
coming coming from you're talking about
a 33 year old law that's been passed but
still being argued about
in congress and the courts and
communities today
and that show you just how far things
have come
and as far as reagan's statement the
other night it's
it was outrageous he made a blanket
indictment of just about every black
civil rights leader there was and that
showed you his mentality
of the total situation and it must be
true because
earlier that day on a different network
one of his best friends was on there
mike deaver
he made the exact same utterance that
reagan made which means he made it
in public and also in private to people
who were close to him
and he wonder why people perceived him
as being against
blacks thank you pittsburgh i'd like to
respond to the part
of the caller's part about the brown
decision still being argued about today
it's it's true that there are arguments
ongoing about how to enforce school
desegregation about whether affirmative
actions or busing or
what what sort of what you can do about
the and preserve the neighborhood
schools
what is not true however and i hope does
not become true
is that brown the fundamental philosophy
that democracy and racial
enforced racial segregation cannot lie
down together
is not a question in the official
ideology of the country racism
is perceived to be a taboo
it is perceived to be outside the
mainstream of acceptable
democratic ideology the brown decision
was indispensable for that
the civil rights movement in that
respect probably could not have taken
place had it not been the bre
for the brown decision that's why to me
it was so uncanny
that king's career he took his first
church in 54 the year of the brown
decision
and only 14 years later was killed in 68
at the time that basically that whole
movement to establish
freedom and deepen our conception of
freedom and democracy
disintegrated so that the years 1954 to
68
i regard as the civil rights years and
because king was at the heart of it as
the king years that's what i'm arguing
about but
that principle as yet as of yet thank
goodness
the principles in the brown decision are
not really subject to bait in
to debate in american politics they are
accepted oakland california good evening
yeah uh mr ketchum that was a good
question you asked about
why there haven't been any bestsellers
on this subject generally i
read almost all the books on the subject
for the last 30 years
and i would like to ask mr branch if he
doesn't agree with me that
the last truly honest book written on
this subject was written by alexis de
tocqueville in 1848
in democracy in america and and along
that line i'd like to ask if he
would reflect on this president monroe
president jefferson and alexis de
tocqueville all
said that if the black culture
or the black people and the white people
in
the country ever tried to join together
it would result in a conflict in which
one or the other would destroy the other
and isn't it the fact that since 1954
that's exactly what has happened
and that is that the white culture has
attempted to
integrate the black subculture and in
the process of doing it
the black subculture has defeated the
white culture
and if you look at the language and the
popular art
and the family and the sexual mores and
the destruction of the cities
and the whole range of civilization in
the united states
the the uh thing that was talked about
by alexis de tocqueville in his book
has happened and that this bodes
extremely ill
for the whole future of the blacks in
the united states and that the if this
process continues
it can only lead to a terrible conflict
in which the blacks will be defeated and
probably
expelled from the united states oakland
thank you for the call
i don't know what to say with that i i
can't imagine that the caller really
expects the blacks to be expelled from
the united states
toefl jefferson madison all those people
were writing at a time when
it was illegal in all the southern
states to teach a single
black free or slave the elements of
literacy
you're talking about a completely
different era this is why throughout our
history it has been the race issue that
has deepened
that jefferson's intuition of what
democracy means all men are created
equal meaning that they all have equal
spirits
jefferson knew that that intuition
pointed toward racial equality which is
why he said
when i consider the condition of the
slaves i tremble for my country before i
know that god is just what he meant by
that was that
god would not allow even jefferson's god
and he was a pretty vague
deist would not allow forever those
conditions to uh
to persist as to the cultures i think
the cultures
have uh come together in some respects
with uh great harmony many the blues the
jazz many things uh that are treasured
at literature
in the arts from black culture have been
appreciated in white culture and vice
versa
yes it is it is true that we have a
tremendous problems in our cities and
that is the
the great challenge that faces us now
it's almost an echo of the 1950s because
you're beginning to have people
say and fear privately but not openly
that
that underclass may be like
regard that underclass the way people
regarded all blacks in the 1950s
the way uh conservative whites or
anti-black whites did that
that there there's nothing you can do
about them they're separate species well
that's a very dangerous idea in the
civil rights movement
this obliterated the idea of inherent
and complete racial inferiority in the
1950s and
we need somebody to come forward with
ideas and the openness and the
uh and the courage to uh to obliterate
the idea about the underclass in the
1990s and 80s and 90s
september of 1958 martin luther king jr
was
arrested what effect did this incident
have on future the civil rights movement
well this is during the period in 1958
when king was trying to
duplicate by preaching the montgomery
movement uh
throughout the south it was an effort
that frustrated him no end
an effort that was a failure
it got him right back into the headlines
he
he was preaching non-stop uh several
hundred
sermons a year was largely ignored but
there in that trial
he was manhandled and put right back
into the headline
shortly after that just a matter of
weeks he was he was stabbed in harlem
it was a terrible period for him raleigh
north carolina good evening
hello i was wondering um uh the offer i
just read a review today on your book
it was a good one in raleigh um
i was i just wanted to ask what you
might think of the ncaa
that just came out with higher standards
for 1991
for students to get financial aid
and secondly have you read ellen bloom's
book where he
talks about the lowering of standards
you know to admit blacks in the
university and so on
and also he comments about the black
separatist movements
on in the university campus i'm also
a graduate student at nc state and we
had a
situation just recently where they
wanted more black professors and they
didn't like the grading system
and the fact that only four percent of
the blacks do
graduate from nc state which is very bad
but i think you hit something on this
cultural literacy thing that's going on
right now this big rage in universities
about
how lacking it is would you comment on
that for me
thank you well i um
i think that uh the professor bloom
uh talking about the lowering of
standards he's basically what he's
talking about is the lowering of
classical
educational standards in the united
states insofar as you're talking about
that i'm
i'm a conservative i believe in people
being able to know how to write
people being able to know literacy to
know history to know the classics
and i think there's a great decline in
those virtues
and those attainments throughout our
society
but unfortunately i think that it's
common to whites as well as blacks in my
own
dealings with students i'm shocked that
i
dealing with college students whose
papers
don't don't use english grammar
correctly they don't uh they can't write
a paragraph
i don't really see it as something that
that that's that race bound i think that
it is a
an effect of the television age and
great prosperity
uh and a certain perhaps laxity in the
in the culture
but for people to use that as an offer
as an opportunity to sound off
particularly against the blacks
given the fact that it's only four
generations ago that blacks were
forbidden to learn how to read it seems
to me
to be mistaking mistaking one's
own hostility for a much much deeper
challenge as to the question of
cultural literacy and separatism i think
basically that both races have turned
inward a great deal in the last 10
15 years i don't think that this is just
a phenomenon of the reagan years i think
it's
been going along a lot longer than that
and that
there's a certain cyclical aspect to
this and uh
and that dr king's principles would
would mourn it and try to do something i
mean king
basically taught us and preached
that in today's world whatever color you
are you're a minority
whether you're white whether you're
black whether you're yellow or whatever
and that your ability to survive
uh quite apart from your ability to feel
something larger than yourself or make a
contri
contribution to the to the larger world
and to live out the most conservative
and deepest values of
practically all religions requires you
to have a respect and an interest in
peoples of other cultures franklin lakes
new jersey good evening
yes i am a baby boomer born after 1960.
it's very clear to me that the alleged
civil rights
movement is a conspiracy of the jewish
zionist underworld and
blacks to overthrow white european
people in america
ultimately the aim i believe is genocide
that's clear to uh i think many white
people across this nation
caller let me ask you how is that clear
to you
it's clear by the movies being made by
the
bias in the media and by the
infiltration of the federal government
and the
policies of the federal government
toward white people
can you give us an example perhaps uh
putting white children on
putting white children on buses and and
shipping them to ghettos
so what do you think of war gentlemen oh
boy
thanks for the call new jersey taylor
branch uh
i don't know it's it's it's it's hard to
know how to respond to somebody like
that that's one of the great challenges
of
for king it's amazing to me to hear his
speeches when he would respond to
someone
like that a white person given the fact
that
throughout our history whites have had
all the advantages and privileges of the
education system of the government of
the economy
has been almost entirely in white
control and for somebody like that to
have hatred for people who historically
have been
among the most disadvantaged and in many
cases remain that way
is a great tragedy of our of of not only
religion but of
democracy and basically fundamental
human decency i
king was very understanding of people
like that
one of the most remarkable things about
his sermons is that even bull connor who
was bent upon
who was sending those dogs in those fire
hoses king never referred to him openly
as an evil man or as an
enemy he preached love your enemies
because he felt that that was the only
way
to have hopes of reconciliation that
could triumph over the hatred he wanted
to create less hatred in the world not
more hatred and
in that sense he was talking about
principles that were larger than race
i remember at the height of the
birmingham movement
there were some private sermons where he
would say
this is not essentially a racial
question this is a question of how much
hatred there is in the world this is a
question of justice and
injustice and justice is in some
respects the closest approximation that
society has to the kind of love that we
envision in religion
so these are contributions and a
redemptive spirit that
that i think would speak well to the
gentleman who senses a conspiracy of
genocide
escondido california good evening yes
sir
there's something that's been bothering
me about dr king for
quite a while uh concerns his personal
life
from what i've read that he is a great
womanizer
now in order to be so and if that's true
he would have to lie to his family
deceive them
uh i understood that women were
delivered to him by his
aides now i have trouble reconciling his
greatness with that kind of behavior i
wish you could help me with that
thank you taylor branch well i
um i think many callers will have
difficulty with that when they read the
stories of
of dr king's private life i think that
they were
do you get into that in your book into
his private life i yes i do because the
wiretaps here it's not very much in this
book because the private life
was really a consequence of the wiretaps
and this book largely
ends with the wiretaps but i do
there were there were occasions when
women in fact that photograph
of dr king being manhandled was at a
trial of ralph abernathy who was
accused of assaulting a member of his
church who claimed
who claimed that abernathy had seduced
his wife and that man chased abernathy
down the main street of montgomery with
a meat cleaver and a gun
right down the middle of montgomery uh
and
tried to kill him and king was showing
up for a trial in that case when he was
manhandled
and what was interesting in a way was
that the photographs of king being
manhandled completely obliterated
the substance of what that case was
about about uh abernathy running down
the street
and the reason part of the reason for
that was that the issues of
of sex across the races back then were
so radioactive that nobody wanted to
talk about it that was partly because of
the
the morality or the conditions of the
press
most people that i'm aware of who who
dislike
dr king on account of his
private life would have just would have
disliked dr king anyhow
one of the constant things that you
always find in the civil rights movement
is
people want to find one
thing even if it's small you know i
agree with everything he did but that
last demonstration went a little too far
and uh or or he should have
made a more of an effort to conciliate
here before he did that
and uh the remarkable thing about it is
just that one little thing
turns everything dr king did
on its head and enables people's whole
empathy
to run against him and
that to me is a sign of somebody who
doesn't who has not really
absorbed what king went through in his
life what the movement was about what
these students did what they sacrificed
that's one reason that i wanted to write
the book however i do want to say in the
behalf of the caller on the chance and i
think that my experience is that this is
a slim
chance that he's somebody who was who
who was devoted if not to dr king to
these principles which i think go to the
root of democracy and religion
but was but felt depre shocked or
felt wounded i have found people like
that i have found people who came across
flying on an airplane who were who were
devoted to this black and white
and all of a sudden they overheard some
of the members of dr dr king himself and
some of his people
talking about extramarital affairs and
laughing and joking about that who never
recovered from it i write about a woman
here who committed suicide
i don't doubt for a minute the sincerity
of
some people who are destroyed by the
notion
that sexual immorality and great
principles in both religion and politics
don't mix
those are very difficult issues i'm
writing a lot about them right now in in
the next volume where king's private
life becomes the subject of blackmail
um but very very similar things happen
with john kennedy in politics and of
course happened with
a lot of great figures in religion
including saint augustine
whose confessions the great line from
that that king always quoted was
lord make me pure but not yet
sex and religion have a long history
going back a long time
there's no accident that the early
christian fathers on the basis of very
little contemporary evidence turned
jesus into a celibate and
and turned the essence of religion into
a
a matter of sexual abstinence that
these things have a long history of
the relationship between sex and
religion and politics and so they are
difficult issues and i'm not
minimizing the concerns of what the
caller said except that to say that in
my um
and mostly in my experience people
who've expressed that
were resistant to dr king before then
and if you answer that question they
find something else to be resistant to
about 20 minutes left with taylor branch
author of parting the waters
our international phone number if you're
watching us outside the united states is
202
737-6734 we'd like to hear from you
birmingham alabama thanks for your
patience
yes uh mr branch yes sir hi uh this is
david branch from
atlanta oh how are you very good
i was wondering um if you could comment
on the progression of your next book as
to
how the civil rights movement would
progress into
the 70s and to tell us if you were going
to be making any tours throughout the
southeast
oh i definitely plan to go in the
southeast um
that's my brother by the way and he's in
school in birmingham
where i have four chapters of the book
and i've told him that i really want to
come to birmingham because i want to go
to the places where the movement
occurred
oh that's my little brother i will come
to the
to the south david and i will come see
you as soon as i get there i plan to go
to the birmingham church
i plan to go to the birmingham jail i've
spoken in
jail in new york already it's been quite
an eye-opening experience and
i hope to go all the way all through
there since we have
had your brother on the line i want to
ask you about one of the stories i read
and how you came to write this book
there was a story about something
your father did we talked about dr
king's father tell us about
your father and the effect he had on how
you approach this book
well i don't think that he had an effect
on how i approached the book
uh uh well maybe he did let me think of
it i
thought of that my father uh is in the
dry cleaning business in atlanta that's
what i grew up in during that period
when we were anti-political not just
non-political but anti-political growing
up in the south
and he's a pretty conservative
businessman
a small businessman as most people in
dry cleaning business are my mother was
always kind of the u.n liberal in the
family who who believed in
progressive race relations and saw
segregation as a curse
my father basically thought that hard
work was the answer to everything it
still does
there was a period in 1965 i believe
when there
came to be publicity about a county in
georgia
north of atlanta forsyth county in which
it was
fabled in fact more than fabled it was
reported in the newspaper that
they set signs along the county border
saying blacks
the sun will not set on blacks
[ __ ] was afraid the sun will not set
on a [ __ ] and forsyth county
the reason that they did that was
because there was a
resort lake up there lake lanier and
wealthy people from atlanta were
building lakeside homes they were
beginning to take their maids up there
and occasionally they would spend the
night
and it got to be an issue because the
clan was burning crosses and basically
trying to enforce
this famous proud boast that
black people could not spend the night
in forsyth county something about it
triggered my father he heard that hosea
williams
and there's almost nobody in the civil
rights movement who's more unlike my
father than hosea williams who dr king
called my wild man my rebel my castro
my gorilla hosea williams
decided that he was going to lead a in
effect a wagon train up to forsyth
county to prove that blacks could spend
the night there and he called for
volunteers
without telling us my father volunteered
some of his laundry trucks and himself
and went up there and joined this
um crusade and went up there and they
they circled their cars
out in the middle of a field in forsyth
county like you know like
settlers circling the wagon train and
sure enough the clan came and threw
rocks and there were
fights and skirmishes all night and the
state patrol had to come
the next thing we knew daddy came home
the next morning and this thing was all
in the papers and he sheepishly admitted
that he had gone there had never really
talked about it very much
there was something about it that was so
elemental
that he in spite of the fact that he's a
conservative republican
had to take action i really admired that
um
and liked it a great deal there are
and it's and it's like a lot of things
about civil rights it's discovering
things about people that you didn't know
and for people who dislike the whole
notion of civil rights are always
finding some reason to resist it for
protection
there are all these stories of
breakthroughs where people can do
something and discover that they have
common ground across
barriers that of race of religion or age
or something that they didn't know were
there
and that's what movement is that sense
of movement and
for king and the people in the civil
rights movement that sense of
movement really always awakens a new
sense of brotherhood across those
barriers and to them you're really
experiencing
democracy and i think that my father did
that that night it certainly had a
profound effect on me
and opened him up so that thereafter
even though he recoiled a little bit
from the flamboyance of demonstrations
he could understand how somebody
under the right circumstances could feel
compelled to do something and make a
demonstration of values like that
fort worth texas good evening hello uh
i'll tell you what mr branch is really
nice to listen to he's one of your
the guests that does actually answer the
questions and tell us what he thinks i
really
appreciate that uh i would like to take
a little bit of an issue with one of the
earlier callers he said
speaking about right-wing violence he
said a right-winger killed jfk and that
went by and i couldn't hardly believe
that but
anyway i thought it was kind of shocking
and also
shocking or surprising was that nixon
was very close to ml king in the late
50s i think that's very interesting i'm
definitely going to have to buy this
children's book
nixon nixon was very close to to king
what was interesting was also that billy
graham was as far as i've been able to
find
billy graham is the only white man that
dr
king invited to and asked to call by his
birth name what he called his birth name
or his real name which was mike
most of dr king's colleague old friends
call him mike because dr king was born
mike king and only in 1934 when he was
five did daddy king
change his own name to martin luther
king and change
young mike's name to martin luther king
jr because he had been a junior
so that relationship between nixon and
now
and king came at a period when most
blacks were voting republican the only
vote of dr
kings himself that i've ever been able
to discern that he
said who he voted for was that he voted
for eisenhower in 1956.
today when 95 percent of blacks vote
democratic it's almost hard to believe
that there was a period
when not only most blacks but dr king
the father of the civil rights movement
voted for a republican president uh
maybe maybe something like that would
happen again but i'm sorry did i cut you
off in a question
uh mr fort worth oh fort worth is gone
fort worth i'm sorry
but you brought up the name change why
did daddy king decide to change their
names
i i referred earlier in the program to
this stupendous compression of daddy
king's
education from going to somebody from uh
bumpkin
forcing himself through school in
college and then marrying the
daughter of the great preacher and
taking over a bankrupt church and in the
space of a few years
two years really in the teeth of the
depression turning it into the richest
church in
atlanta black church it was a
at the end of that he was record
rewarded in 1934 by his church with a
trip to the holy land and
all throughout europe which for a black
man of daddy
that's like the millennium for for daddy
king somebody who really left
as he said smelling like a mule and not
hardly able to read and write
as an adult that came to atlanta to all
of a sudden
be sent to europe by and all through
this
was a great thing and the headlines in
the atlanta
daily world the black newspaper reverend
king royally
welcomed on return from europe and had
in type this big that's what i meant
about the black preacher being so
big i mean in even today in black
newspapers preacher news goes on the
front page oftentimes what's happening
at a church a church a pulpit
changing uh physician well this was
giant this was like
d-day headlines and before
daddy king who was michael king then
went to germany that trip culminated in
the world baptist convention in
germany and they were going to go and
visit
all of the martin luther shrines in
germany the ver
the birthplace of the protestant church
and also the anabaptist movement
and so daddy king i believe in
celebration
of his stupendous leap to the stars i
mean
it's a story books romance of
awesome proportions to celebrate that
chose to rename himself
after this great conservative rebel
there are a lot of similarities between
dr
martin luther and daddy king a rebel
against
authority and a man of ferocious will
and yet
martin luther was quite a conservative
himself and that he demanded
obedience to his uh to the doctrines of
his reformed
church daddy king changed his name to
martin luther i believe in honor of that
trip and the fact that he was going to
luther's home and mike since his son was
mike jr
didn't make sense to change his name it
wouldn't make sense to have martin
luther king senior and michael king jr
so
he changed young martin's name young
michael's name to
martin and dr king as we know him the
young one who was
the name was changed at five always
resisted it he didn't
like the fact that his name was changed
he called himself ml he called himself
mike and into adulthood in private and
whenever he was saying something
intimate with his friends he would call
them
ask them to call him michael um he
didn't like it and it was really only
the outside world during the montgomery
bus boycott white reporters
didn't like ml king they wanted to know
his real name
and they finally time magazine when he
earned his first time of the year
time man of the year they put reverend
martin luther king
jr and in a public sense that was really
the birth of his name
and in that story he said perhaps and
it was a significant perhaps because he
was always shy about making such a claim
perhaps we have earned our right to the
name
in his conduct through the montgomery
bus boycott spokane washington thanks
for your patience
i forgot what i was going to say i'm so
enthralled with mr
branch's articulate so expression
let me ask you spokane have you had a
chance to read his book no but i'm going
to
thank you spokane bless you but
really i feel most fortunate that's why
i love c-span i mean
here i am uh fortunate enough to listen
to an educated intelligent
very articulate interesting man and like
i was in college you know going to a
lecture i
it's most rewarding but what i wanted to
say and i hope that this doesn't dismay
you because it's
very apparent that you care
very much for martin luther king jr as i
do also
in fact i remember reading my first
biography of
martin luther king and i was shocked to
find that he was so intelligent
so well educated you know i guess i
expect him to be
you know someone that just said i mean
they could not speak well but anyway
i'm getting older now over i'm 65 but
all my life i
have prided myself on having empathy
with the black
people and and cheering them on and
being happy for every little thing they
might
might achieve but you know i saw the
movie
the color purple and i have to say
that if that was an honest uh portrayal
of of black people
at that time i felt them to be i felt
alien i felt they were alien
to me and to my um
[Applause]
a way of life i guess and i don't say
this in a
i'm not trying to be unkind or superior
or
or anything i just felt them
to be alien is em could you
comment on that for me please thank you
spokane it's hard to know exactly what
to
sense the caller means alien but since
we're trying to be honest here and talk
about things that may be considered
taboo of course the color purple wasn't
was largely about two things it was
about
incest among blacks in an
older time and it was about violence and
depravity of black men
toward their own women toward their own
families that sort of thing and to that
extent if somebody is watching this they
might
say my gosh what an uncivilized behavior
but again i think that we have to be
sensitive to where
uh where we're coming from and have to
be sensitive to what created that i mean
people tend to say well these were
slaves and it doesn't excuse later
behavior but you have to remember that
they were
enslaved they were made slaves we made
them slaves and
at the time of the civil war 10 percent
of american blacks were
mulattos and none of those were very
few if any of those were seductions
of of whites by blacks it was the other
way around
and of course under slavery the blacks
had no
rights of chastity they had no rights of
marriage marriage was not a legal
institution
so um and of course
when you're speaking saying where how
many generations beyond that it's not
not an easy thing and as far as i know
there was never an institution
set up by the u.s government in the wake
of slavery
to deal with the friedman's bureau dealt
to some degree with problems of
displacement and economics but
never anybody anybody to deal with the
advance the
consequences of a culture that was
forcibly and legally deprived
all rights of christian marriage
christian home ownership
and of literacy so these are these are
very very difficult issues
i might also say that one of the things
that made dr king
so interesting was that he said that
in many respects blacks have
had a demographic history always
that whites may find themselves
approaching that
if for no other reason if you lack
empathy
you should study us because throughout
the 20th century the one constant among
black
college education is that three out of
four or two out of three
black college graduates have been women
that was true in 1900 it's true now
in 1900 probably 9 out of 10 white
college graduates were men
now it's more than 55 percent of the
white college graduates are women
the black economy has been troubled
throughout history by the fact that it
had a very low industrial base and was
based largely on services
the white economy is headed in that
direction
a lot of these things are very very um
complex but powerful social forces and
they
had these effects in the color purple
and i don't think that we should uh
be too shocked to find that the
consequences of slavery on the family
and sexual morays and the violence and
the self-respect
of men among black men
are are still with us in many respects
frankfurt indiana good evening
thank you very much granted all the
inequities and the abuses
of the black community in the years gone
by
what can we do in the 1990s to
whether we're black white or whatever to
get the blacks into the mainstream get
them to accept more responsibility
and be a part of this wonderful country
what can we do
to get this job done and i appreciate
your conversation
i think that that's a very very good
question
and i think that a lot of it one of the
first things i would say
is that we need to put more heart and
more belief back into the public school
system it has to be reform
we perhaps need to do something about
the fact that we have
in effect a noose of affluence around a
lot of cities
in which the geographic
restrictions of cities mean that the tax
base erodes as the whites flee
they take the money to the suburbs they
refuse to
allow the cities to expand therefore the
cities have less money the value of the
real estate goes down the tax base goes
down the schools decline
the few whites who were there leave
again and it's a vicious cycle
that's a terrible political problem that
we have
allowed to develop in our cities but i
also think sir that
one of the problems is and this is
something that you will hear whispered
about among black leaders in cities
a lot of them don't have any that many
good ideas about what to do in the
underclass either
they have tended to perpetuate the
notion
which is a civil rights notion that the
underclass will be lifted up by a mass
march behind the moses behind the mayor
behind a presidential candidate
that may not be the model that's most
relevant the jewish model of family by
family degree by degree
mom and pop shop to college
may be a more relevant model in the
1980s and 1990s as we're trying to enter
the computer age
but what we have to understand is the
aching
reality if that is true and that is the
model that
throws itself up to us that that would
mean for a culture i mean jewish culture
developed for fifteen hundred two
thousand years all around literacy and
being in
intellectualism and a preserved written
culture
when in the united states for blacks uh
for
most of the time that they've been in
the united states literacy was not only
not a virtue that they practiced but it
was denied to them by law so that
that path is harder and that means that
if it is the path as opposed to the
political we've got to work that much
harder on the schools and
and throwing ourselves together to to
make that uh work
daytona beach we have just a few short
seconds left
i'd like to make a few points first of
all i think this all men are created
equal from the declaration of
independence is probably the most
frequently misinterpreted and out of
context
phrase in the history of humanity
jefferson meant
clearly that it only meant that people
had
were to have equal rights under the law
they were trying to deny king george's
right to rule
they did not mean to imply that blacks
were in any way equal to rights
as a matter of fact they didn't even
legally recognize blacks as being men
even jefferson who i mean excuse me
lincoln who freed the slaves did not
think that blacks were equal to whites
okay and secondly i'd like to comment
that
the other caller earlier who made the
remark about genocide i believe that in
a very subtle way
he was absolutely correct um if you
remember
crystal knox in germany which was a
prelim prelude to the holocaust
that was touched off by the
assassination of a jew i mean excuse me
of a german diplomat by a jew
daytona beach i'm going to let you go on
that point because we are just about out
of time just a few seconds
on that taylor branch i'm very sorry to
end it on that
the caller misinterprets all men are
created equal it doesn't mean created
equal in endowments it means created
equal in spirit it means that's what we
mean when we say that votes should count
the same and that means the black man's
vote should count the same as a white
man's vote
that's the intuition and the spirit that
no human life is worth more than another
human life that's the democratic
uh intuition and throughout our history
it's been the race issue that has forced
us to deepen the understanding of what
jefferson meant by that kind of
democracy
the book is parting the waters america
in the king years 1954 to 1963.
author is taylor branch it's out by
simon schuster in your bookstores
everywhere as they say thank you for
being with us i'd also like to thank our
viewers this evening for
your calls and your comments have a good
evening thank you
if you have further questions or
comments for our guest
taylor branch you can contact his
publisher simon
schuster the firm's address is 1230
avenue of the americas new york new york
the zip code one zero zero two zero
coming up next we close out our
retrospective look at past inaugurals
with speeches by richard nixon
jimmy carter and ronald reagan that
begins after this
short break for schedule information
bye